[Music]
wreckit-ralph - already broke the
internet and it's not even out yet but
who are the actresses behind the Disney
Princesses stay tuned to hear who will
replace Snow White's iconic voice don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video now let's check
out the real-life wreck-it Ralph two
Disney Princesses this whole knowledge
is what you want
do you ever bother to ask what I want
Merida let's start with one of our
favorite princesses with the best
Scottish accent ever it's very rare to
even hear a disney princess with an
accent so Merida has a special place in
our hearts and her accent belongs to the
gorgeous Scottish voice of Kelly
Macdonald Kelly of course played the
original Merida and she'll come back to
have an appearance or two more than she
did in the trailer and yes Merida did
actually appear in the trailer guys
although Kelly Macdonald doesn't really
have Merida's curly haired look our fav
Disney Princess just wouldn't be the
same without Kelly's voice Mulan
speaking of princesses you thought you
didn't see in the wreckit-ralph -
trailer Mulan was there - sure she
didn't speak much but she definitely
will speak in the actual movie actress
ming-na wen is said to play Milan in the
record Ralph - movie and yup she's the
same actress that played in the original
Mulan how cool is it that ming-na wen is
still the real life Mulan 20 years after
the movie she might look slightly
different than Mulan herself but meaing
is still a total babe nicki minaj fans
should know that she actually played
chun-li in street fighter Rapunzel did
you know that everyone's favor Mandy
Moore is actually the original voice of
Rapunzel she might not be a real
princess in real life but we did see her
sing in a princess movie before
remember the Princess Diaries she's
saying stupid Cupid during that beach
scene being a princess is totally her
style so it's only natural that she
comes back as Rapunzel we didn't see
much of her a pencil in the trailer
either but we do have a question will
Pascal make an appearance - thank you
only I don't dance Elsa idina menzel is
the queen of not getting enough credit
for her work did you know she played
Shelby Corcoran on Glee but she really
put things in perspective when she told
us all to let it go
the song echoed in our heads four months
after frozen made its first debut and we
apologize if we just made you sing it
again
Idina of course plays Elsa and since her
character became one of the most popular
Disney Princesses ever it's pretty much
a given that she comes back in wreck-it
Ralph to onna little sisters always
managed to steal the Thunder and
everyone fell in love with onna so of
course we want her back - Anna is played
by the one and only Kristen Bell known
for her work on shows like Gossip Girl
and Veronica Mars
she might not look exactly like onna so
let's be honest
her personality is just as cheery and
outgoing Kristen will be back in
wreck-it Ralph - a Zanna and we couldn't
be more excited to hear her voice again
will there be sisterly fights
random interactions we'll have to wait
and see Tiana Tiana is known as one of
the most underrated princesses ever but
she's definitely one of our favorites we
didn't see her much in the record Ralph
- trailer but anika Noni Rose is
credited in the second movie so we have
a feeling we'll see a lot more of her
Anika is the ultimate Tiana but just in
case you're not sure where you've heard
her voice before you might want to
re-watch Dreamgirls
she played Laurel Robinson Anika
originally voiced Tiana in the Sofia the
first series and she had several other
appearances but we're most excited to
see her interact with other Disney
Princesses Pocahontas now let's talk
about another totally underrated actress
who has embodied plenty of Native
American characters during her acting
and voiceover career it's Irene Bernard
this talented lady played the original
Pocahontas and more than 20 years later
we get to see her again
strangely enough did you know that our
dream didn't actually get to play
Pocahontas in the new world movie which
was totally about Pocahontas she had to
play Pocahontas as mother her appearance
in wreck-it Ralph - will finally allow
her to reclaim her role as Pocahontas
since it's a new world movie Ariel she's
got whozits and whatzits galore Ariel is
back - although we all know Ariel's look
was inspired by the actress Alyssa
Milano the actual real-life Ariel is
Jodi Benson
in fact Jodi is the one that can
actually brag about having the longest
resume when it comes to reprising her
role as Ariel in various miniseries
video games and other appearances after
the original movie but for some reason
worse
feel more excited to hear Jodi Benson's
voice again as Ariel in wreckit-ralph to
Snow White
okay let's be honest we all wondered
what will happen is Snow White who can
fill the shoes to become her voice since
well the real Snow White is no longer
alive and her voice was so iconic and
unique Disney didn't allow her to act
ever again
rumor has it pamela ribbon fills the
voice of snow white for wreckit-ralph -
just like the original Snow White Pamela
doesn't really have an extensive acting
portfolio but she has done a lot of
behind the scenes work in fact Pamela
herself wrote Moana the movie as well as
our very own record Ralph - that's right
along with writing the movie she'll also
become a real-life Snow White and that's
it for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]